what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel Studios is doing something
that they have never done before they
are releasing a series in what they call
binge form meaning they are dropping all
of the episodes at once they're doing
this for the echo series which is coming
out on November 29th on November 29th
you can watch every single episode but
they are not doing this for all of their
shows they're just doing this for Echo
right now and it is part of a plan that
Marvel Studios has they are doing this
for a very intentional reason and that
reason is Marvel Studios really is
changing how they do things but most
importantly they are kind of changing
the phase 5 and phase six schedules and
not just release dates but adding and
possibly taking away projects right now
we know that Marvel Studios is preparing
for a pretty big announcement and some
insiders like Alex P from
thecosmiccircus.com have confirmed this
Marvel Studios they are prepping for
that announcement now we've been talking
about this announcement coming for a
while now on the channel and like we've
been talking about it is most likely
coming during sdcc However unfortunately
as we have heard the wga strike the
writer's Guild of America strike that is
happening right now might delay this
just a little bit but that still won't
stop Marvel Studios from making some
pretty big announcements at sdcc now
just to clarify this big announcement
coming from Marvel Studios does not have
anything to do with Spider-Man 4. we did
talk recently about a big announcement
coming for Tom Holland Spider-Man 4
possibly coming at sdcc and maybe even
before this is still looking to be the
same this has nothing unfortunately to
do with Marvel Studios as far as the
announcement is concerned Sony always
takes it into their own hands to
announce a title or a release date or a
new film that's always up to Sony
unfortunately even when Marvel Studios
goes to reveal their 5 and Phase 6 slate
completely in its entirety unless Sony
has already put out the release date for
Spider-Man 4. they actually don't
include it in their slate even though it
technically is a part of their slate but
this big announcement has nothing to do
with Spider-Man 4. they're doing that on
their own and as far as everything that
we've heard that is still on track to
come either before or at sdcc hopefully
fingers crossed but Marvel is doing
something different they are actually
changing what they had planned already
and the reason that they're doing this
is very good news they're trying to be
better there's been a lot of recent news
lately about Marvel Studios getting new
directors getting new riders for
projects doing reshoots completely
scrapping scripts for some projects like
blade and completely redoing them this
is all part of Marvel Studios simply
trying to become better and yes it does
have to do with the quantity of projects
that Marvel Studios was producing at the
time and Kevin feige and Bob Iger CEO of
Disney have already told us yeah they're
gonna cut back and focus more on quality
but yesterday was the first pretty big
sign that they are indeed going to be
doing some things differently to make
sure that quality can be achieved and
the first thing they did was make Echo
that binge type of release and it seems
like they did this so their schedule
isn't that packed now before you go on
and state that Echo sounds like it's
going to be terrible if Marvel Studios
is going to just release all episodes at
once maybe don't jump to that conclusion
yet we have some insiders like can we
get some toast state that the echo
series he's heard is actually quite good
and Daredevil is going to appear in
episode 2 which I know people are going
to really love and you don't have to
wait till the end of the season to get
it but not that it really matters you
can watch them all at once but as far as
Marvel Studios new plan is concerned
they were trying to introduce a lot of
new characters and talk about a lot of
characters who weren't necessarily huge
big main characters in the comics
characters that aren't so well known to
the general population of the world and
it looks like they might be switching
back to doing projects or around more
well-known characters not all of their
projects still some projects about these
lesser known ones but it does seem like
they want to focus on bigger ones and
what's Happening Here is we're going to
actually see a big shift in Phase 5 and
phase six for example Echo and Loki are
coming out this year and they're coming
out a month apart basically Loki season
2 is going to debut on October 6th and
no not all episodes are coming out at
once this is going to be a weekly series
then at the end of November 29th that's
when we get the echo Series so not far
after Loki but what's interesting is
that Agatha coven of chaos and iron
heart were supposed to come out this
year now they have been pushed back to
next year or maybe even after that so at
San Diego Comic-Con we've heard that
Kevin feige has a pretty big
announcement and based off of what we've
heard so far that announcement is going
to be phase six and the rearrangement of
phase five so what exactly can we expect
from Kevin feige we'll talk about that
in just a bit but first big thank you to
comic book direct for sponsoring this
video they have have created a website
and company that makes comic book
shopping the easiest it can possibly be
they deliver Comics straight to your
door you can get one-off Comics or you
can sign up for an entire run and get a
pretty big discount if you do so and
they'll ship the latest issue right to
your door each week they have the latest
from Marvel if you're trying to keep up
to date with all the recent projects
they have the latest from DC as well and
it's an all-in-one shop for your Comics
everything that you need in one place
you can sign up for a membership to get
free shipping and a mystery box each
month and the next 100 people to sign up
get 20 off their first order using the
link in the description down below so
the biggest thing I think we're
expecting from Kevin feige at San Diego
Comic-Con is the full release of phase
six and this is something that everyone
should be super excited for because I
believe they're going to introduce
projects that we really didn't know
about I think Kevin feige is going to
slide some projects in there that really
weren't on our radar now we do know
about Deadpool 3 of course they've
already announced that so that's going
into phase six of course but then he'll
announce movies like Doctor Strange 3.
this movie kind of has to take place
before Secret Wars it doesn't
necessarily have to take place before
the King Dynasty but definitely before
Secret Wars because we know it's all
about incursions Clea grabbed Doctor
Strange at the end of Multiverse Madness
in the post-credits scene and said he
caused an incursion and it even revealed
that he had his third eye so we have to
figure out what that was about we have
to see if he was actually able to
reverse an incursion because Cleo said
they're gonna fix it so I'm expecting a
doctor strange three thrown in there for
phase six another one that is probably
going to be pretty important is Shang
Chi too this has already been confirmed
to be happening and since shangchi's
rings are apparently the results of King
Technology I'm assuming they're gonna
want this to happen either before the
King Dynasty or before Secret Wars now
obviously we have the Fantastic Four
coming in phase six we know that however
we don't know who exactly is going to be
playing The Fantastic Four members so
perhaps we could be getting a cast
announcement if the rumors are true and
Marvel Studios really has a huge
announcement prepared for sdcc the first
thing that comes to my mind is the
announcement of the Fantastic Four team
the cast who is going to be playing
Marvel's first family then another major
possibility that I think would just
freak everybody out that we've kind of
talked about but I don't think people
are really expecting to happen anytime
soon is a Scarlet Witch solo film
however if we think about it it does
make sense for this to happen before
Secret Wars and Wanda now kind of has
knowledge about the Multiverse she'll
probably be a key player in the fight
against Kang we know she's going to
return but we also know that a lot of
things kind of have to be addressed
before Secret Wars because she can't
just come back and be a hero after
killing a lot of very good people and
she could have possibly caused an
incursion as well so I wouldn't be that
surprised if physics contained a Scarlet
Witch movie now there have also been a
lot of specials that are rumored to be
coming like Anova special or a Mephisto
special and even Ghost Writer I would
love for Kevin feige to announce all of
these or if not some of these I would
also love to hear something about World
War Hulk a lot of insiders state that
this movie is coming it's only a debate
on whether it's coming before or after
Secret Wars so phase six or phase seven
but we know the Hulk is on Earth we know
he has a son we know he has connected
with She-Hulk so he's probably going to
join the fight in secret Wars and
probably the King Dynasty as well now
there have been rumors that we could
possibly be getting an Illuminati movie
or special presentation of some sort and
this is very interesting because we have
heard that some of the projects that
happened between King Dynasty and Secret
Wars will take place in other universes
so if this is true that means that this
could take place in the same universe
that the other Illuminati existed in
that Wanda wiped out or it could be the
establishment of an Illuminati in our
universe connected to other universes
who are about to fight King and this is
something that I have been wanting for a
pretty long time since we found out
about the Multiverse Saga I've wanted a
multiversal illuminati that way it would
consist of the leaders of each Universe
in the comics the Illuminati consists of
the leaders of each group like the X-Men
the Fantastic Four The Avengers
Etc I would like the Multiverse
Illuminati to be whoever is in charge of
basically the entire universe then the
leader of each Universe gets together
with the leaders of the others in some
type of a void maybe someplace outside
of space and time maybe the quantum
realm or maybe just one universe but
this is what I'm hoping to see after
Kang Dynasty when the Avengers and our
other Heroes realize hey we can't do
this alone we need the heroes from the
other universes to help and fight Kang
and his variants we have to go find them
and talk to them I hope that's what gets
established a multiversal team hopefully
the Illuminati but the name doesn't
particularly matter as long as we get
some sort of multiversal Avengers X-Men
Fantastic Four team and speaking of huge
announcements it would be insane if
Kevin feige announced an X-Men movie I
do not believe this is going to happen
please don't get your hopes up for this
I firmly believe the X-Men are coming in
Phase 7 after Secret Wars but you never
know I could be wrong I hope I'm wrong
maybe Kevin feige will make an X-Men
announcement but again I'm not really
planning on that but let me know what
you would like to hear announced for
phase six in the comments down below and
what have I mentioned that you are most
excited about don't forget to like this
video And subscribe and leave a comment
down below to enter a giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick we pick a
winner at the end of each month also be
sure to check out our website WE Post
every day on there our patreon and our
Discord if you want to interact with
other awesome people you can also follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
beep